go back they want it so there's a
question from zoom that is around how
the controls are an indicator of viral
density mom and contagiousness so the
question specifically is I'm not sure
how the controls are an indicator of
viral density that is actually
significantly contagious maybe they're
not if they aren't then how should we
think about the control so I don't know
if you want to go through a little or if
you know you want to sort of talk a
little bit about that
so in these people they don't anything
they are not addressing whether the
amount of violence they define are
actually able to contain the potential
and compete continue and to make you
seek because yeah there is there is
research showing that viral loads do
make a difference how much fire you get
exposed but in this case the controls
are actually not a not not to basically
prove that this viral can be transmitted
to another person but also to prove to
control that you can actually in this
individual we see example if I'm sick
and I get an no swab and I actually find
a lot of fire so I validate first this
person is actually sick and then you can
basically you can see that when they
exhale breath you are sharing and it's
like a small dose of load of virus this
doesn't mean that it has contagious
potential or not now it just means that
the virus is out there so in order to
see the other part you can sort of
thinking a follow-up experiment no
having M having sort of like a test
animal exposed to these three breath
particles and then monitor the animal to
see whether the animal gets sick or not
and then you can basically determine the
load of hours that you need in the air
in order to make this thing and make it
a possibility so it goes into more and
more experiments than in these people
they don't address so we are not saying
that when you read out your journal
infected
people immediately we're saying that you
are leaving the virus there that's it
yeah I think that's thank you so much
for that clarification I think that's
really important you know whenever we
think about experimental evaluation as a
style of scientific reasoning we do have
to think about you know what it is that
we're asking and then interpret the data
based on the question that we're asking
and sort of like it's it's hard to not
jump right and that's a really important
fact thing about science is that you can
only answer the question you're asking
what the data that you have to represent
that answer you can't really extrapolate
unless you can do a new whole new
experiment and all and generate a whole
nother set of data so thank you for that
exactly yeah
we we don't speculate about everything
research yeah again question to this
might not be something that was covered
in the course of this paper
it comes from Swan heed and the question
is can a plastic reinforcement and I
guess this is one of those face shields
further prevent the availability of
nasal droplets or aerosols to pass
through so the disease nodding this
research and I haven't read any like
proper research showing that it does but
my guess is that because these are very
dense polymers that actually you are not
gonna be able to the virus is not gonna
get able to go through it maybe around
it and the fact that you are wearing a
mask and then the shield can increase
the protection that people have around
so here's a really intuitive question I
like this one do you know if the
rhinovirus is smaller than the corona
virus you know and maybe that could be
an explanation around why it penetrates
this masks these masks more than the
corona virus so actually yeah the Rhino
Mar is smaller and it has like a smaller
a coat so the the corner viruses are
actually a pretty pretty big variance
for these kind of versus so if you
talked about your only keys they will
tell you coronavirus are
and they have huge D means random bars
are much more smaller and like a simple
in their structures than corn Americana
very sexual very very clever virus yeah
they're there it's really interesting
because I think they're for RNA viruses
the average size of the RNA genome is
about nine kilobases but for a corona
virus it's 32 kilobases and it's it's
pretty I don't know this is amazing
biology right here I know it's like in a
we're in a situation where folks are
definitely being impacted and our lives
are being impacted but there's no
denying that the science of these
particles are is incredible
yeah yeah I heard that too that it
really puzzles everybody how these virus
can actually disease such as beak in RNA
molecule insider and being effective
so moving back to the data we have a
question from Galen which is for the
percentages that calculated in table one
B what was the number of subjects tests
with and without the masks because then
sample size seems small yeah so the
sample sizes are small so a number total
is basically the total amount of people
who are being tested so yeah it's just
three is ten and out of those ten three
three from three individuals they were
able to find virus in the droplets by
example and here you have 11 27 27 we
learned 27 32 these numbers for sure are
small and you can see here even though
you see I'm a reduction reduction to
zero for the carnivals in this a row
he's still not significantly
significantly a true it's a great it
doesn't reach the statistics to say this
is a hundred percent true it's close
enough but I said like in order to make
it more robust you should sample more
people my guess is
one thing is this in order to conduct
clinical research it's not that easy
now to gather humans who are actually
sick not feeling very well keep them in
the hospital for longer asking them to
do stuff a testing them extensively it's
in inmates it's a hassle to work with
people and get bigger and bigger numbers
it's a gimme more complicated also we
all get coronaviruses in every winter is
very common not copied nineteen other
kind of art coronaviruses and most of us
don't go to the hospital when we get a
cold you know you have to be pretty sick
so and I would guess that because this
research is so important now that is
very to publish it as soon as possible
so it's really be available instead of
just waiting longer for this important
information that those aren't guesses
I'm not sure yeah I think that's a
probably a pretty fair estimation of why
you we have we are seeing so little what
we call in science is n or n is like the
number that the number of data points
that you have yeah there's probably a
lot of practical barriers to that and
along those lines we do have a question
that asks around what he means on the
graphs and the tables so I don't know if
you want to sort of allude to our our
coveted P in science level so P is
basically um it's basically I'm it's a
number that we use for statistics so
it's not a simple in science it's not as
simple as saying like oh I have I don't
know 10 points here that about 10 to the
4 and I have 4 here that below so this
is different no we need to have
something that is actually telling us
this is really really different and
makes
since and for Dan we use statistics so
we use different statistical tests to
compare it and our data and then through
the tests that these are mathematical
algorithms what they do is just
basically look at the probability that
this is a model of chances of this is
actually a real difference
no because you can be measuring
something that is just random chances so
for those you get a p-value that it's it
can be kind of big so not only in size
we put a cutoff in P values are no
smaller than 0.05 you can even go
smaller depending on the kind of data
that you're looking for so that means
that out of the you have like less than
5% chances that these happens randomly
so if that's what the p-value saying so
in this case the difference here means
that you have 7% chances that this is
like a random situation that is not
actually true and you put cutoff there
depending on the kind of science data
that you have I'm not a statistician
this is a whole different art form but
it's it's how you buddy that you what
you're looking at yeah and we've
arbitrarily set like you know 95%
confidence intervals so we would have a
p-value of 0.05 to indicate or below to
indicate if something is a real change
versus a not difference but this isn't
by no means meant to be sort of like the
final anything it's sort of like you
know there's a limitation to your
p-value so that might be going a little
bit deeper into the weeds but I think
it's important that we we also are
acknowledging there are limitations to
the p-value and and also I hope all of
you will take a statistics class because
this is how life works nah get rid of
calculus and Clutton high school and
take statistics instead that's my
soapbox and I'll get off of it right now
no I
I would say it also as a side thing
study see you can have good people use
and prove differences and then you also
have to use your brain and your
analytical thinking to prove to make
sure it is actually made any like any
sense no you can have differences that
come from completely other reasons and
not it doesn't have any biological like
importance at all so you have to think
about the results it doesn't matter
whether you have a number along the
thing yeah and actually so this is this
is something that's under discussion as
to whether we should have these
arbitrary settings of you know the 95%
interval say this is significant the 99
percent into there builds to say this is
super significant but yeah this is I
completely agree with Francisco in the
sense that you this is this has to be a
conversation that's had and we can't
just decide on the basis of an arbitrary
cutoff but further purposes of the
research that we we do on an average day
and for experiments that have a lot of
data points it's usually quite it's a
very useful metric for us I feel like I
got a question from IBP last time as
well the question is what portion of
exhaled air is larger droplets versus
aerosols do you know that from the data
mmm I don't remember I had to I mean
maybe Dini do you remember um we can
share the paper after this maybe we can
share we'll share the paper and we'll
answer this on our Facebook stream so
let's get back to that question yeah
easy sound good question though yes yes
all right so let's move in to a little
bit more around aerosolized particles
so if ericeira aerosol ice particles are
at zero when wearing a mask
how are surgical masks less effective
than n95 masks oh very nice
I've seen research suggesting that
ninety-five n95 masks don't protect you
very well against Arizona particles how
does a square with that research so I
don't know if this is something that
you'll be able to answer based on the
paper here um and we can certainly point
people toward the ask a scientist tool
but I don't know Fran if you have
anything to say about that
um so the in fact they are not a hundred
percent covering everything that goes
out of your mouth it's just basically
like particles that are finer like
bigger than leads in 95 I don't know the
night has come from somewhere I don't
remember I actually wear this mask every
day and I haven't looked into that in
for my research and yeah you can it
become so it can be that you have these
answers coming out but maybe because the
corona virus is a big particle it just
stays inside and you don't need to take
their birthday the viral particles in
the exhaled breath using the n95 I will
say that the n95 for sure are like more
protective than regular surgical masks
and that's all I know I mean just for
wearing them you kind of know the in 95
whenever you get like not I don't think
now they're doing it but I remember when
I was in when I had to start wearing the
n95 I went through a process of
evaluation to find the right a 95 that
fit exactly in my face and they did a
bunch of tests to make sure the Excel
breath and they inhale press in the
amount of particles are coming in and
cetera so it's not just a matter of them
we're in 95 and you're gonna be
protected no it just it's a little bit
more tricky than them yeah and if I can
add I know that people you know just to
your point regarding the fitting like
there I saw this
I saw this article about how a person is
fit you know in a really serious way
where they have a person where an n95
and then they put them in a chamber and
they sterilize some aspartame so you
know it's that like you know sugar
substitute that you can really taste and
you know if the n95 mask is not fitted
correctly that person would be able to
taste the n95 I'm sorry the aspartame
and they continually go through this
process of spraying the aspartame until
that person cannot taste it you know
they adjust they do mask sizing and
adjustments until that person cannot
taste it and that's how a lot of people
are finished that's one way people can
actually detect if they're n95 fit is
the right fit did you have to go through
that Fran or when you yes not bad it was
basically a specific n95 brand that has
the tubes in so he measured how I don't
remember very well how much air is
coming now whether he's tied hey how I
breathe whether I can smell or feel some
stuff it was a the idea that the
Rockefeller University be good he's just
like a kind of like a sad funny
situation that I'm allergic to mice and
I've worked with mice everyday so I had
to wear this mask but I I donated all of
my masks to the hospital here so I don't
have any one less those yeah a lot of
people who do particularly rodent based
research do develop allergies at some
point and they just it gets to the point
where it's actually dangerous for them
to work the the the previous question is
kind of a good segue into the next one
which is that though the surgical masks
are effective if people don't have the
proper knowledge of how to fit them so
there is no exposure what good are they
and I mean if you don't know how to wear
a mask then leave the n95 to people who
actually need it right now
to be on I think this is to do with a
circle mask so yeah
for the surgical mask so it in the case
of the surgical mask some of us like by
example have a few at home so I'm gonna
like rotate through them and I don't be
posting because now we don't we art like
you need them but if you're going to the
the World Health Organization website
you will find a ton of resource of how
to actually properly put the face man
probably wearing disposes and here I put
on some sort of like some of these in a
slice that they have you have to make
sure you're washing your hands before
you put it you put it only grabbing it
sort of like this side that goes into
your ears then don't touch it that's
something I see everywhere people are
they doing groceries or on the subway
and they just touch it no don't do that
don't touch it and then when you want to
take it off you wash your hands first
and then you take it off so right now
I'm example I'm not disposing these ones
are actually supposed to be single-use
masks because there are not too many
available I'm reusing them in like I
wait so the standard the Rockefeller
University has right now is that you
have you have to wait three days to be
using so you're sure that the virus is
dead if there is any virus there yeah
and I don't think it's really
appreciated that it's not just about
wearing your mask it's also about taking
off you like knowing how to take off
your mask and in science we call that
process of putting on donning your PPE
in the process of taking off doffing
your PPE and it's really important that
you learn how to Don and doff and I will
say just as another sort of element of
being on a soapbox I'm seeing a lot of
people wearing gloves
but like going into their pockets and
picking up their phone and talking on
their phone and putting it to the face
and then touching everything you know
and I just want to make sure that people
don't think that the masks and the
gloves are gonna like you know if you're
not using them correctly then they're
useless materials and so and they are
kind of limited so make sure that when
you're using them you know
that you're using them correctly yeah
one thing about gloves we always said
was that especially in our lab they tend
to be bright purple or something else
the one thing that might do is stop you
from touching your face because as you
see them you're less likely to to want
to at least do that in order to transmit
the virus that's true so in the interest
of time I know there's a ton more
questions and maybe some of these
questions we can just note them and try
to answer a couple of them in the web
archive work we do plan on creating a
little bit of a discussion guide around
each talk so I mean you know for those
of you who didn't get your questions
answered we'll try to do our best to
represent them in the study right up but
in the meantime you know I'd love to
hear friend is there anything that you
want to share you know regarding your
experience with this and presenting this
paper that maybe nobody asked or
something that a question that you have
specifically that you don't have the
answer to you know what you know where
are you on along those lines so I think
in well I I love doing these
presentations I hope everybody really
enjoys it I also learn a lot about a
shading of bread in general it's
something that you don't usually brag
and like look online so one thing that a
like I learn a lot about all these
different laughs here in the u.s. turn
looking on in to the research of these
dynamical process that we go through in
our daily life and it's amazing it's
amazing how much we shared outside and I
also think that for me the main question
in the they were two main questions
right like he linger with me after
reading the paper one was already asked
which is what is they infectious
potential this particle have and I don't
know whether we know so right now people
are studying the effects of a viral you
and how much you need to get seek and
also this is not like a like a super
number question it's very tricky because
everybody also has different genes have
different comorbidities different
situation so it's not that easy to
answer and the other one that I think it
is important to recognize it now a that
many most of the countries are asking
people to wear masks and if you don't
have access to these surgical masks
because now we are leaving them for a
medical staff to wear a like a like a
cloth or something like made of masks
for yourself and we don't know yet
whether this is hundred like really
effective to stop the spreading of the
virus but I think if they tell you to do
it it doesn't harm you no they're not
it's not that terrible to go around with
that cloth in your glove mask you can
make them I mean now I seen in Vogue
magazine making them likes to use ones
and you don't make it home and put in a
lot of effort I think that's also a main
question that we must answer also I
carry today's birthday so for me all the
disposable stuff it still hurts my heart
so to see so much waste of plastic so if
the cloth works I'll rather have that to
be honest so before we disappear
the limos una pregunta en espanol ah
awesome dad okay estas Mira's Mouton
ECAM bein is possibly in Proximus onions
los cambios enemy rose a victim la
capacidad de las máscaras
para proteger a la gente y los
coronavirus siempre se ron grandes a por
lo tanto las máscaras siempre Sarang
igualmente effective us in yo creo que
la coronavirus komatsuna Familia video
siempre van a ser
acidic
see ya de que el futuro siempre Molosser
effective tendría que moutarde una forma
dramatical para que cambiar el tamaño
e composition y para ESO yo creo que de
foyer pass a ser otro tipo kimochi
evolution book e LD r OC muta de todas
maneras tiene una bahá u n bajo nivel de
muta C&A pero SI vomit are it lo que se
para que even torment a este video space
I said in video Steve está en la socio
mana siempre y Nova effect on o esta el
fuerte como hora por que la logic adesso
el que en general CLV rose dis minnow un
poco suka pass en f XE osa yo Mata tanto
sacis a como é menos a receive o save ah
ah expand Irma's entonces final no fear
owes me no hurry co sexpanda mihaela
policy on he Logano
I love Vera's kiss on Maharis Yvonne's
cookies a persona Coons and feminine
ihsan ila antes y Wayne Medina
toss a este video said para que en el
tiempo
say a menos Annie no y por lo tanto it
wallows are Maccabee mockery of a sarah
fatigue oh yeah thank you yeah yeah yeah
so um I think you could stop sharing
your screen and thank you again for it
to everybody who joined us for the
second installment of d4p
and please make sure that you take our
survey I will email everybody with
information about the survey if you
missed it and just let us know how we're
doing or you can email outreach at
Rockefeller edu thank you again to all
of the people who are making this happen
from our friends at scientists Inc my
colleagues at rocky do you to Eva and
Lizzie from w CMC and sloan-kettering
and to Fran thank you you think it's
such a pleasure working with you
thank you for always saying
when we ask you to do stuff for us it
was really really fantastic thank you I
really appreciate if you have any
question you can also ask me I think my
email a somewhere yeah we'll share it
and be on the lookout for the archives
of the videos for d4p we'll get that we
are working on getting them online and
be on the lookout we will be with you
again
next Wednesday at 3:30 p.m. where we
will have a postdoc from rockefeller
talk about the proximal origin of
Tsarskoe b2 which basically is
demonstrating how we know that the Stars
Kobe - virus came from a bet so thank
you again be in touch
like us on Facebook I think I'm supposed
to say all these things I'm trying to
like mimic only two people that my kids
watch you know smash that like button or
whatever they say I don't know although
they're saying it for YouTube not for
Facebook but feel free like us on
Facebook and follow us on Twitter follow
us on Instagram we'll have more Defour P
lovely goodness coming your way in a
week's time so thank you again and I'll
we'll see you soon
próxima down by Lucy